[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because i am joined by nathan kress you
all know him from icarly as he is freddy
and it's exciting because season two is
out now when new episodes drop on
paramount plus every friday how are you
doing today nathan i'm great man thank
you so much for having me thanks for
coming on man i'm absolutely loving the
reboot and what i wonder while watching
it from your point of view
were you hesitant at all when the idea
first came up to reboot the show
oh yeah
big big time hesitation
i think you know
it's so hard because everyone calls it
a reboot
and i don't know if that's really what
it is or not i feel like revival is
probably the word that we should be
using but nobody does because it's a lot
harder to say and everyone just calls
everything a reboot but when they
when my brain first went to reboot when
i thought about this show i was like
well no one likes those
that's
that's just an automatic
uh it just feels like
a cash grab it feels like we have
nothing else to do so let's just do the
same thing that we've done
but then
when i started hearing about the
creative
and i started hearing
what the idea really was about the show
not just that we're doing the same thing
again but that we're just
taking this universe these characters
and completely pulling them out of this
kid world and making it a show that is
specifically for adults it's just that
it was for the kids who were kids back
in the day
and now we've aged along with them that
was when i started going
okay
well i don't have anything to compare
that to because right no one else has
done that before not that i'm aware of
and so you know in a way it was scary
because no one else has done that before
so we didn't really have any
blueprint on how to do it but that was
what was exciting about it was we get
the chance to kind of break some new
ground and do something that hasn't
really been done before so
that was ultimately what freaked me out
the most but also what excited me the
most about this whole thing was just
that
we are doing something familiar
you know people want to call it a reboot
but it is
there's some key differences there and i
think that that is what people have
really latched onto and why it's been
successful and why people have enjoyed
it is because it's really not the same
thing
it's a whole different voice and you
know grant some people probably don't
like it for that reason but sure we we
had to show progression for that reason
yeah i love that answer and yeah i'll
never call it a reboot again i'm sorry i
even said i'm sorry
i don't want it to feel like i'm calling
you out because that's what everybody
calls it it's you and everybody else
no i love it i i feel like i've learned
this is great and i i'm wondering too
you i think you just mentioned it too
that so you would say that this revival
is more of
is it
also geared more towards an older
audience like 10 people who are doubting
like oh am i too old to watch this like
can we enjoy it as well yeah the whole
point is there is now no one too old to
watch it and to be fair that was our
desire with the original show too we
wanted to have a show that
ages 5 to 95 could sit down and still
laugh at the same jokes together in the
same gag so
in this way in in a sense the the
content is probably not as kid friendly
so it definitely is geared more toward
the um maybe 15 to 95
right age range um so uh we it we have
in a sense narrowed ourselves a little
bit but i think the whole point now is
that we're very much opening ourselves
up toward adult situations adult
problems uh relatable things that the
millennial audience can appreciate and
to be fair you know it's funny because
sometimes i feel like i'm aged out of
the show because there are so many jokes
that i did not understand at all
when we were making it and i was just
going guys i don't know if this is that
funny but then it would come out and
they were the ones that would go totally
viral they were the ones that people
were laughing at the most and then i
just realized oh maybe i'm just an old
fart
you know like
i'm not even 30 yet but there's already
things that i'm not cool enough to
understand so there are definitely
references and jokes that the
even older than me side of the audience
might not necessarily understand it it's
certainly
niche in the late teens to 20s but um
but again the the goal is that everybody
can have something to laugh at on this
show yeah and i love that and i like you
mentioned the niche thing and it's doing
something different i think which
everyone can appreciate and
do you think too it's it's so cool to
see that like you have a trajectory
where you were a teen when you were on
it and it's first run and now you're
older is it like do you find things more
enjoyable now doing it as you're older
on set with the same cast or is it like
different like what would you kind of
say is maybe comparison
yeah i think um
in us in a sense
some things are easier like i'm not in
school
when i'm trying to do this thing so i'm
not i'm not only trying to
shoot the finale but then also take my
final right an hour later so there's
there was a lot of split focus there
where i was really trying to focus on
academics at the same time as work and
that's something that i don't have to
worry about anymore so but i've traded
it off now for
um at least in this season uh producing
the show and also directing several
episodes of the show so my mental
bandwidth is now focused on not just
what i'm saying and doing as an actor
and and what i'm relating to with
whoever i'm having dialogue with it's
also thinking about pre-production for
the next episode um post-production for
the previous episode so there's still a
lot of things pulling focus but that
is also what has made it so fun is
really feeling like
we as
as the original characters have a a
strong say
in what makes it to screen you know if
there's something that we feel like
isn't authentic to the character or
something that we feel like wouldn't fit
in the universe
uh we're we're very lucky to have a
writing team that's very receptive and
open to that and they really want to
make this a team effort and work
together on it so
um
you know sometimes that can be tricky
when people have different creative
opinions but that's where the dialogue
starts and um and we've gotten i think
to a point where
we're all getting
better and better every week and every
season at
starting to speak the same language and
get on the same page faster and faster
and i think that that is another thing
that has moved it along pretty darn
smoothly
in this sort of adult version because
there could be there's a lot of
opportunity for conflict there because
like i said there is no road map no one
knows exactly what to do
and you get a lot of talented creative
people in a room there's going to be
different ideas floating around
so that was one of the biggest
challenges but also i think one of the
biggest triumphs of the show was
distilling down the best ideas from all
sides and using it to sort of
create this thing under this lens of
the general question what would the fans
want
right um and i think that was our our
ultimate goal and our our top priority
was taking all of our ideas but
filtering it through
what is our audience looking for
sure and i think it's really cool that
you direct and produce on it now and
they did an episode last season and i
wonder too you know do you feel like
from acting at a young age you can
direct now younger actors better on set
do you feel like there's things you
would only know from that experience
that you can kind of almost be a mentor
in a sense definitely that's something
that i've leveraged really from the
beginning we finished icarly in 2012 and
i started directing another nickelodeon
series henry danger in 2014. so pretty
shortly after our run ended i was doing
that and then another nickelodeon show
uh game shakers and it was all you know
very young kids there were adults um of
course in the cast but predominantly it
was these kids who had done very little
work in the past and this was their
first kind of big break you know so i
was definitely able to put myself in
their shoes and and multi-camera
especially is a very difficult medium
because it's this combination of tv and
theater
where you can't move and talk in a
normal way as if you were just walking
around a room in a 360 degree set you
have to make sure that when you're
turning around you have to turn around
in the right direction you know you have
to look over your shoulder toward camera
not away from camera even if it feels
unnatural so there is little there's
these little tips and tricks and things
that i was trying to instill in them
early on with their sort of stage craft
that that i learned you know and that i
was able to sort of leverage myself and
and kind of see those problems
before they happened right and and just
start getting those little things into
their heads and and even just from the
performance side um just knowing from my
from my practice in talking with kids on
those kids shows being able to leverage
that into when we have guest cast that
are kids or talking with jaden who has
become you know
very very very close to a true fake
daughter
right
over over these last couple years i'm
able to talk to her in a way that i know
that i would have understood
back in the day yeah and i think it's
interesting you talking about that
different stage style directing too and
i'm wondering do you plan on do you see
yourself then branching out and doing
more regular type tv directing and film
directing is that something you want to
branch out to yeah you know
multi-camera sitcoms are a warm fuzzy
blanket for me i grew up on them they're
comfortable they are really fun
uh from from the purely logistical
family perspective they're the best
schedule ever right right it's really
hard having a family when you're doing
night shoots on a cw drama
right down down in san pedro you know
and you're never seeing your children so
um i love multicam so much and i
definitely want to use the fact that
icarly is an adult show to leverage that
into me doing other adult shows i know
it's a little bit uncommon for someone
my age to be directing you know these
titans of comedy um and so that's
already something that i'm gonna have to
work through but uh but that is
absolutely something that i want to do
and then ultimately expand those
mindsets and skills into doing the
single camera stuff like you're saying
like single camera tv and features and
everything else so it's all part of the
process
no yeah and i'm excited it's gonna
happen i'm excited to see what you bring
to the table with that too and it's cool
you mentioned family and you know
being a dad now and you have a second
daughter congrats recently thank you um
it's awesome that you do this great
podcast with brett davern radioactive
dad so
do you love doing just podcasting in
general as much as you do the acting and
directing and is this something you
could also see you doing more podcasts
or opening more to that is that
something you really seriously want to
commit time to yeah you know i i think
of all the things podcasting i
it's hard to even consider myself a
podcaster because the show that we do
is essentially just
a candid ad lib conversation that i
liked having with brett every week just
as a friend and as a dad and a fellow
actor and the whole concept of the show
came about when we just sort of realized
you know
if we just did what we're doing right
now sitting at this diner but there was
a microphone right here
this would essentially be a podcast yeah
with with a little bit more structure to
it and granted we tried to do structure
for a while and you know ultimately that
just didn't really we liked it better
just meandering on in our own thoughts
and getting off on tangents aside from
the fact that we like taking you know
user questions uh as kind of our final
segment and dipping our hands into the
mail bag and that's been one of the
super fun things is you know in the same
way that we have grown up with the
icarly generation that watched the show
those people are becoming parents now
and they're starting to have the same
issues that we're going through as
parents you know and and they're asking
questions and we're able to kind of give
advice and speak from our own
experiences and for me that that show is
just catharsis i just like sitting down
with a friend and talking about the
stuff that i'm going through and 90 of
the time it's an issue that he's already
dealt with his kids are a couple years
older than me so he's a little bit of my
dad mentor in a way sure he's he's
worked through some of this stuff so um
it's just nice because
guys don't usually like talking to each
other especially about their problems
so um having
a safe person to to talk with this stuff
about and not only that but we're
recording it for other people to hear so
they get to hear my problems and there's
a very likely chance that they're
dealing with some of them too so um it's
kind of just become this
collaborative therapy time that we all
get to do together and and i hope that
dads especially young dads who are going
through a lot of the stuff with the
young kids just have a
safe place that they can go to
work through our episodes and feel like
they're learning a little something or
they're at the very least not going
through what they're going through alone
yeah and that's awesome that you do that
and i like that you're saying it gives
you catharsis and that it's coming from
a place that's like therapy for you and
that means it's going to connect to many
dads out there so really cool stuff so
everybody check out his podcast
radioactive dads also of course watch
icarly season two it's streaming now a
new episode every friday on paramount
plus
nathan thank you so much for joining me
today and hope to talk to you in the
future steve it was a pleasure thank you
so much for having me